[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's a bit
like boba fett because i'm the most
forgettable thing about my own show
shabow now with episode seven right
around the corner i thought we'd bloom
up this thing one last time and go over
all our theories and predictions that we
have for the finale if you enjoy the
video then please hit the thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the book of boba
fett
okay so in the latest episode of the
show we saw a harrowing flash back to
order 66. in it we watched three jedi
attempt to protect groku but curiously
we're yet to see him be saved fully i
think with this being such a big moment
we need a fan favorite to step in and do
something and having that happen would
break the internet just like luke did
upon his return now though there were a
whole host of jedi's at the temple
during the ambush i think it would be
amazing to see mace windu come back in
one of the coolest scenes in revenge of
the sith he went to confront palpatine
only to suffer from the combo of star
wars tropes which is of course having
his hand cut off before he fell to his
death though he was hurtled through the
skies of coruscent star wars has slowly
started to establish that this isn't a
death sentence notably darth maul was
sliced in two and he fell to his death
but fans loved him so much that they
brought him back in the expanded lore
things like this have been shown in
palpatine osaka and the only person who
hasn't come back is mace windu until now
possibly might be wrong might be wrong
but it's a fan theory yeah so bear with
us now samuel l jackson's stock in
hollywood has only risen since revenge
of the sith and though he was popular
beforehand he's consistently stayed a
big name since he last appeared as windu
both the marvel and star wars franchises
have been bought by disney meaning you
know they might have some corporate
synergy there or something now during
star wars celebration in 2017 the actor
said we all know jedi can fall from
incredible heights and survive so
apparently i am not dead yes i have two
appendages right now but we know the
long and rich history of star wars
characters reappearing with new
appendages since his statement in 2017
jackson has doubled down further by
saying that he definitely wants to come
back and reprise the role of windu this
would tie in really well with the show
as it's a pretty safe bet that a jedi
was the one who saved grogru from the
temple but he has forgotten who it was
due to the trauma of the events i would
love to see may step in may saw the gods
and though i don't necessarily think
that he made it out of core ascent
watching him go in a blaze of glory
would be an awesome send-off for the
character now in episode six we opened
with the marshall cobb van van
refrigeration at the end we watched him
being shot by cad bane and though
initially seemed like he was dead i do
think that he's alive if you rewatch the
scene bane looks to have shot him in the
shoulder and the three-town foe come out
and shout for a medic cad bane is far
too good of a shot to simply keep him
alive accidentally and i think that this
has been done as an intimidation tactic
this too is muradin cobb himself who at
the start of the episode was happy
leaving one of the pikes alive as it
would send a message cadd shot the
sheriff and he also shot the deputy and
likely left cod breathing so that he'd
think about it before rallying freetown
together in order to help boba it makes
sense for van to be left alive and in
doing this he could go and tell the tale
to mando this would make things personal
and lead to a big bant the beef that
could set up a showdown between boba
mando and cadbane we know the series
crips highly from westerns and having
that showdown follow this manner will
keep things in line with that now the
question that remains is how long has
cad bane been working with the pikes in
our cadbane explainer video we discussed
how there were unfinished clone wars
episodes that showed cadbane and boba
working together before they had a
fallout and then dueled it is possible
that this is now canon as in the bad
batch cadbane had a plate on his head
which wasn't there when he showed up in
the main series if bane had been working
for the pikes for a while he could have
started when their first shipment was
threatened and boba demanded payment we
know that tuscans who took barbarian
were apparently killed by a biker gang
but that seemed unlikely considering how
tough the tuscans were it could have
been a false flag with cad actually
being the one who killed them and him
pinning the blame on the bikers would
further tie into their rivalry killing
the tuskins would be a big noble fete i
think cad being behind it will be
something that's revealed in the final
episode now whilst the show has morphed
into mandalorian season 2.5 the core of
the series has really been about boba
fett staking his claim as a crime lord
he has come into direct conflict with
the pike syndicate and you might
remember that they appeared in solo a
star wars story they're making a fortune
running spice on the planet basically
dune what they want and it's clear
they're ready to kill anyone including
madame gaza just to keep the spice
flowing this could be a prelude to a
possible continuation of the ending of
solo and the finale may bring kira back
at the end of solo she was asked to
bring the first light ship to dathomir
where she and maul would work closely
together whilst the solo sequel is yet
to materialize this story progressed
into the superb marvel star wars comics
and we discovered in them that she now
controls crimson dawn now she has come
into conflict with baba before and
during the war of the bounty hunters
storyline she actually stole han solo
from boba whilst he was in carbonite
during crimson reign after the war of
the bounty hunters we learned that kira
had been trained by maul and she went on
an anti-empire tear in order to
destabilize the imperials out of this we
can also hear some notes from the
crimson dawn soundtrack in the theme of
the show
[Music]
you don't get much more subtle than that
and it would be great to see emilia
clark reprise her role with her having
history with boba and the pikes 2. in
crimson range he captured a young girl
who looks strikingly similar to omega
aka boba fett's sister if she is
manipulating the pike syndicate from the
shadows then using an attachment to him
would be one shocking way to do it and
because of this i'd love to see her back
now episode 6 was a gruelling entry that
tugged at the heartstrings as mano
decided to leave grogu so he could
complete his training we got a good look
at the fundamental differences between
the mandalorian and the jedi because the
four more loyal to the core following
their creed rise the jedi must leave the
past behind and form a connection solely
to the force groku is stuck between both
worlds and he can only choose one of
these two ways of life
hold on a second yet i thought this only
the sith stealed in absolutes anyway he
was offered either the armor which is a
metaphor for his past or yoda's
lightsaber which is a symbol of his
potential future though it ended the
episode on the cliffhanger if we look at
the expanded law we can figure out which
one he chose now in this scene luke says
if you choose the armor you'll return to
your friend the mandalorian
but if you choose the lightsaber you
will be the first student in my academy
and i will train you to be a great
jedi
however in the comic star wars the rise
of kylo ren issue 3 kylo states that he
was indeed the first if this is kept in
continuity then captain obvious but it
means that grogu did not choose the
lightsaber however fellownia showed
somewhat disregard for the comics as
yoda's lightsaber was destroyed in them
by darth vader boy i really hope
somebody got fired for that blunder the
comics might be completely ignored but i
do think that grogu will choose to go
back with mando and there was a line
that sort of hinted to him not really
needing any training luke states at one
point to ahsoka that he's not really
learning things he's just remembering
and therefore he already has the skills
grogu being a mandalorian jedi would
also fit in very well with the story of
tor vissler who was the first of his
kind while grogu could be that
considering kylo did say he was the
first student it would indicate that the
little guy chose to return to his
adopted dad this will allow him to ride
in the space on the n1 starfighter but
it would also go beyond that mando has
been unable to wield the darksaber
because he's clearly distracted by grogu
and thus them being reunited i think
will make the weapon lighter for him as
he'll now be more focused now one plot
point that has been quietly brewing in
the background is the rancor that was
given to baba by the hutts whilst we
didn't expect him to ride it right away
this moment is clearly being saved for
the final battle in the series training
rancors to write them is nothing new to
star wars with the witches of dathomir
having ridden them which was given lip
service to by danny trejo on top of this
he provided some more about the rancors
and how whilst they're bred for fighting
they can be quite loving and incredibly
loyal this somewhat mirrors boba fett
being a clone as he and his brothers
were born for battle and apparently that
was that however over the course of the
star wars saga we've seen how clones
have actually built personalities and
form tight bonds with one another when
he takes the rancor and rides it he will
fully become himself no one others
perceive him as like a clone or bounty
hunter but who he has chosen to live as
riding the rancor is also symbolic
showing his dominance and taming of a
wild beast just like he'll need to tame
the mythosaur if he's to take back
mandalore now with cad bane and possibly
kira being blast from the pass for bauba
who else could come back well the most
obvious answer would be han solo while
the two have been expanded outside of
the main sagas barbara taking in han
solo successfully was a huge moment in
the original trilogy if han somehow
returns to star wars using the same
magic that was used on luke skywalker
then it would be something else as
harrison ford is probably the biggest
actor to come out of the franchise i say
probably yeah definitely now this kind
of ties into my next theory which is
that lucan and leia will be reunited on
screen one final time one thing that we
never got in the sequel trilogy was the
trio reunited i think it would massively
elevate the series if it gave us an
image of them back together han and leia
might even bring their young son ben
with them and just in the same way we
saw luke's academy being built we could
also get a tease of its downfall if they
arrive with their young son we're almost
at the end of the video but lastly i'd
love to see the show pick one of the big
moments from the legends series in above
like that we watched as barbara climbed
out of the sarlacc and he went out into
the galaxy to get revenge on han solo of
the series handful boba and eventually
knocked him back into the sarlacc pit
which is where the character died would
just be pretty funny to see him wind up
back there and probably the biggest
troll way for the series to finish
anyway that's the video we had to end on
the worst theory but i hope you enjoyed
the full breakdown and all our
predictions i do think that fat will be
allowed to remain on tatooine because
it's better the devil you know and the
republic might want someone respectful
running the crime syndicates there
rather than the hudson pikes whether you
disagree or agree let me know below and
as a thank you you'll be entered into
our june giveaway which ends on the 28th
of feb all you have to do to begin with
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theories
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the sixth episode which
will be linked on screen right now we
went over all the easter eggs we could
find and gave our predictions for the
future so definitely go check it out
right after this without the way thanks
for sitting through the video i've been
poor let's see in the next one take care
peace